Guten Morgen. Ich bin Dr. Erbilen. Heute bin ich zuständiger Ersten für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Ich würde gerne zuerst ein paar Personen mit zu einer Fragen stellen.
Dann können wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden besprechen.
Alles klar?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Herd Gustav. Gustav ist mein Vorname.
Herd ist der Nachname.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Vorname, G-U-S-T-A-V Gustav.
Ja.
Und der Nachname, Herd, H-E-R-D.
Okay. Vielen Dank.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Herr Herd.
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
1953.
Okay. Können Sie bitte Tag und Monate sein?
Erster Mai.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Halt.
Ich bin ungefähr 179 groß.
Wie viel wegen Sie?
80 Kilo.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Wie kann ich Ihnen halten?
Ich habe so technisch Schmerzen in meiner Brust.
Und Luftnot.
Okay.
Können Sie bitte ganz genau
den Ort beschreiben?
Ich merke es.
Kann ich nicht. Hier.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Die sind plötzlich aufgetreten.
Plötzlich.
Sind die Schmerzen nur stehend oder auch dumpfend?
Können Sie ganz genau beschreiben?
Ich kann das nicht genau beschreiben.
Ich merke immer nur so, wie so ein Stechen.
Steilende Schmerzen sind irgendwo hinaus.
Ja, in die ganze Brust.
Ein bisschen in den Rücken.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen irgendwelche Auslöse für diese Schmerzen aufgefallen?
Nein.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit gestern, also in der Nacht, hat das angefangen.
Und heute Morgen habe ich das gar nicht mehr ausgehalten.
Deswegen hat meine Frau gesagt, hat die Rettungsdienst gerufen.
Sie sind mit Rettungswagen geliefert.
Ja.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Zuhause oder beim Rettungswagen?
Ob der Rettungswagen mir etwas gegeben hat, weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe eine Infusion im Rettungswagen bekommen.
Ob der Motor ist mir etwas gegeben hat, weiß ich nicht.
Kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Aber ich habe gar nicht einen genommen.
Okay.
Sind diese Schmerzen erstmalig oder haben Sie früher beschwerten?
Nein, ich habe das zum ersten Mal.
Okay.
Wie war die Schmerzen im Verlauf?
Sind sie schlimmer geworden?
Ja, klar, schlimmer geworden.
Ja, in der Nacht hat es angefangen.
Ich sage ja, heute Morgen war es so schlimm,
dass meine Frau den Rettungswagen gerufen hat.
Genau.
Jetzt können Sie bitte diese Schmerzintensität auf eine Schmerzkala beurteilen,
wobei ein sehr leicht unartigbares Schmerz entspricht.
Ich verstehe nicht, was Sie meinen.
Was heißt Schmerzskala?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Es gibt eine Schala von 1 bis 10.
Ein ist sehr leicht, aber 10 unerträglichen Schmerzen sind.
Ach so, 8 würde ich sagen.
8, okay.
Herr Hart, zuerst möchte ich Ihre Unterbreche, diese Gespräche.
Ich möchte zuerst Ihre Vital-Zeichen überprüfen.
Sie werde ich an den Monitor schließen.
Dann können wir...
An den Monitor anschließen.
An den oder an die?
Anschließen.
Anschließen, okay.
Jetzt wird alles überprüft.
Können wir weiterprüfen?
Ja, gerne.
Okay.
Herr Hart, diese Beschwerden beim Ruchen aufgetreten, oder?
Ja, ich habe im Bett gelegen.
Ich habe geschlafen und konnte nicht schlafen,
weil ich so stark Schmerzen hatte und auch Luftnot.
Ja, Luftnot.
Die beiden sind im Ruchen aufgetreten.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzstorpern?
Ich habe jetzt, seitdem ich diese Luftnot habe, auch Herzrasen.
Okay.
Ich merke, dass das Herz schneller wird.
Haben Sie Schweißausbrüche oder Kaltschweiß?
Nein, aber mir geht es nicht gut.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Ein wenig, ja.
Waren Sie schon mal unmächtig geworden?
Ja.
Oder schwarz vor Augen?
Sind Sie schon mal unmächtig geworden?
Ja. Nein.
Okay.
Wie schlecht geht es?
Was meinen Sie, wann und wie gut geht es?
Seit gestern?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übelt?
Nein.
Übelkeit habe ich nicht, aber mir geht es nicht gut.
Ich fühle mich einfach nicht gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, die Schwester hat eben gemessen.
Ich habe keinen Fieber.
Okay.
Sie haben abgeschlagen, heitja?
Kann ich auch nicht sagen.
Mir geht es einfach nicht gut.
Ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Okay.
Ich habe Schmerzen, ich habe etwas Luftnot.
Mein Herz legt etwas schnell.
Ich fühle mich einfach nicht gut.
Ich werde auch Schmerzmittel geben.
Hab ich eine Medikamentalergie?
Medikamentalergie?
Ja, Medikamentalergie.
Ja, Penicillin.
Penicillin. Okay.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich habe auch Schmerzmittel gegeben.
Danke.
Ich möchte schon, dass es besser wird.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Wie meinen Sie allgemein?
Ich meine, jetzt geht es wenig gut.
Jetzt habe ich keinen Appetit.
Ja, früher.
Allgemein.
Allgemein, ja, ich meine allgemein.
Ja, allgemein habe ich kein Problem mit meinem Appetit.
Ja, wissen Sie, es ist so.
Ich bin ja vor zwei Jahren operiert worden.
Da hatte ich Darmkrebs.
Ja, seit zwei Jahren.
Und dann habe ich viel abgenommen.
Und jetzt ist es so, dass ich wieder ganz normal wieder essen kann.
Okay.
Wie viel Küle abgenommen?
Ich habe nach der Operation noch viel abgenommen.
Ja, ich habe wieder zugenommen.
Jetzt ist Ihr Gewicht normal.
Ja, stabil, mein Sie.
Jetzt ist mein Gewicht stabil.
Ich nehme nicht mehr.
Ich habe zugenommen wieder.
Nach der Operation habe ich abgenommen.
Das war eine echt schwere Zeit.
Aber danach habe ich wieder zugenommen.
Jetzt geht es mir eigentlich.
Ich habe einen guten Appetit wieder seit einhalb Jahren.
Seitdem ich operiert worden bin.
Ja, alles klar.
Sehr gut.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf normalerweise?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut.
Manchmal muss ich auch nicht stehen.
Ein paar Mal, weil ich auf die Toilette muss.
Ein paar Mal.
Zwei Mal.
Manchmal einmal, manchmal zweimal.
Ja, in der Nacht.
Okay.
Ein Schlaf ist kein Problem.
Können Sie in Bett flachlegen oder brauchen Sie mehrere Kiste?
Kisten.
Nein, eigentlich.
Bis jetzt habe ich gut geschlafen.
Heute Nacht natürlich nicht, weil ich Luft noterte.
Ich habe fast gesessen im Bett.
Normalerweise habe ich keine Probleme.
Normalerweise.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhlverhältnis?
Gibt es Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Ihr Stuhlverhältnis sagt man nicht.
Das heißt,
wir haben das in der Karstschild-Ilich-Genis.
Stuhlverhalten.
Wie ist der Stuhlverhältnis?
Ja, aber da muss man sagen, genau.
Mein Stuhlverhältnis.
Wie meinen Sie das mit Stuhlverhalten?
Haben Sie Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Ja, seit der Damop habe ich eher Durchfall.
Okay.
Aber nicht so stark.
Ich nehme damit,
weil wissen Sie, das tut sonst weh.
Ich bin ja operiert worden.
Deswegen habe ich immer etwas nehmen,
damit mein Stuhlgang weich ist.
Okay.
Movikohl nehme ich ein.
Zwei Mal, morgens und mittags.
Movikohl.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Das klappt gut.
Ist Ihnen Herz-Rhythmusstörungen bekannt?
Herz-Rhythmusstörungen eigentlich nicht.
Ist Ihnen Bein-Ödem auf gefallen?
Mehrzahl und immer sind Ihnen Bein-Ödem auf gefallen?
Oder sind Ihnen Herz-Rhythmusstörungen aufgefallen?
Ist Ihnen eine Herz-Rhythmusstörung bekannt?
Oder sind Ihnen Bein-Ödem aufgefallen?
Auf jeden Fall sind Bein-Ödem bei mehrzahl.
Eigentlich nicht.
Aber wenn ich jetzt mal überlege,
das ist aber jetzt schon etwas her.
Vor vier Tagen hatte ich ein Schwello am rechten Bein.
Aber das ist dann weggegangen nach zwei Tagen.
Okay.
Rechten Bein.
Vor vier Tagen haben Sie
eine ungewöhnliche Erreignis.
Eine Perletzung oder
eine lange Reise?
Sie meinen, ob ich verreift bin.
Eine lange Reise gemacht habe vor einiger Zeit.
Die letzte Zeit.
Die letzte Zeit, meinen Sie jetzt?
Ja, genau.
Nein.
Also ich habe keine längere Reise gemacht.
Ich bin eigentlich zu Hause.
Ich fahre nicht viel weg.
Keine Verletzung gibt es auch.
Nein.
Eigentlich habe ich mich nicht verletzt.
War damals Schmerz an Bein?
In der Wade ja, das hat sehr gespannt.
Okay.
Diese Bein-Ödem war erstmalig?
Oder früher haben Sie schon mal gehabt?
Nein.
bisschen komisch, weil das nur rechts war. Okay, okay, ich verstehe. Ja, jetzt, ich möchte
ein paar Fragen über Ihre Vorgeschichte stellen, Herr Hart. Ich möchte jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer
Vorgeschichte stellen. Oder ich möchte noch etwas über Ihre Vorgeschichte wissen. Ich möchte etwas
über Ihre Vorgeschichte wissen oder ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen.
Okay, ja gerne. Haben Sie Zuckerkrankheit oder Wuletochdruck? Vorgeschichte, Sie meinen
Vorerkrankungen. Ja, was habe ich dafür? Vorgeschichte. Ist nicht schlimm. Vorgeschichte heißt, ich habe
gedacht mit, also Vorgeschichte hätten Sie auch sagen können, Sie hätten sagen können, ich
möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen, dann hätten Sie mich aber fragen müssen
über meinen Darmkrebs. Das passt dann, das geht. Das ist die Vorgeschichte. Die Vorgeschichte ist,
ich habe schon mal einen Darmkrebs gehabt. Sie meinen aber Vorerkrankungen, ne? Ja. Vorerkrankungen,
was meinen Sie damit? Also ich nehme Movikol ein, meinen Sie Medikamente? Ja, was meinen Sie?
Zuckerkrankheit? Zuckerkrankheit habe ich nicht. Ein hohen Blutdruck habe ich auch nicht. Ich habe
auch keine Zuckerkrankheit. Eigentlich habe ich nur, war ich einmal gesund, bis dieser blöde
Darmkrebs gekommen ist. Und seitdem nehme ich eben? Ja, waren, haben Sie diese Kolonkarz-Norm,
Diagnose gehabt? Wie meinen Sie? Wie meinen Sie, ich weiß nicht, wann Kolonkarz hingest? Ja,
Darmkrebs, ich meine. Das war, das kann ich Ihnen ganz genau sagen, das war 2021
im November. Wissen Sie, da hatte ich auf einmal Blut im Stuhl. Das heißt, ich habe es gesehen,
dass ich Blut hatte und ich hatte so ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen. Und dann hat mein Arzt gesagt,
wir machen mal eine Darmspiegelung und dann haben die das gesehen. Und röderweise haben
die gesagt, dass das ein Darmkrebs ist und ich muss operiert werden, aber die haben gesagt,
ich habe Glück gehabt und es ist alles gut. Ach ja, präuht mir. Und trotzdem, aber
trotzdem habe ich, trotzdem habe ich Chemo gekriegt. Okay. Chemo und Operationen, ja. Genau.
Wie ist Ihre Nachsorgeuntersuchung für Darmkrebs?
Am Anfang, am Anfang bin ich alle drei Monate, bin ich in meinem, ins Krankenhaus,
wo ich operiert worden bin. Und jetzt soll ich einmal im Jahr soll ich. Und ich war jetzt letztes
Jahr, war ich schon und dieses Jahr war ich auch schon. Okay, sehr gut. Okay. So, Sie nehmen,
gibt es noch andere Medikamente? Ich nehme eigentlich nur Movikol ein und ein Vitamine,
die hat meine Frau mir gekauft. Wissen Sie die anderen Namen Medikamenten? Nein, das weiß ich nicht.
Wissen Sie, meine Frau möchte einfach, dass ich wieder gesund werde. Die kauft mir ganz viel,
die kauft mir ganz viel Vitamine und so. Ich nehme die einfach rein. Ich weiß nicht,
wie die heißen. Okay, so, wir können mit Ihrer Frau sprechen. Hatten Sie nur Darmkrebs,
Krebsoperation oder gibt es noch etwas? Ich war eigentlich immer gesund. Ich habe nur Darmkrebs
Operation gehabt. Als Kind sind meine Mandeln, als Kind früher sind meine Mandeln rausgemacht worden.
Ich überlege gerade, nein. Okay. Ich hatte auch mal ein, ja, ich hatte auch mal ein Sportunfall
und da ist mir der Arm gebrochen worden, da habe ich aber nur ein Gips gekriegt. Nein,
also Operation hatte ich nur Darm und ja, das andere, was ich Ihnen gesagt habe.
Welche Arm? Der linke Arm. Okay, so, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie auf Penicillin allergisch sind.
Gibt es noch andere allergische Substanz? Nein, nur Penicillin.
Wie usert Sie diese Allergie? Diese Penicillinallergie? Genau. Oh, da habe ich mal Penicillin gekriegt im
Krankenhaus und dann bin ich fast weg gewesen. Ich war vom Kreislauf ja fast weg und dann haben
die mir ganz viele Medikamente gegeben, dann ging es mir wieder gut. Okay, okay. So, haben Sie
Unterträglichkeiten? Nicht, dass ich wusste. Okay, ja, jetzt ich möchte einfach fragen,
über Ihre Gewohnheit stellen, zu Ihrer Gewohnheit, oder?
Sie haben auch über Ihre Gewohnheit. Ich möchte einfach fragen, zu Ihrem Gewohnheiten stellen,
doch, richtig. Ja, ich habe lange Jahre geraucht bis zu meiner Darm, okay, dann habe ich aufgehört.
Okay, wie lange haben Sie? Ungefähr, ungefähr 30 Jahre. Okay, und wie viel Zigarette haben Sie damals
geraucht pro Tag? Eine Packung. Ja, trinken Sie Alkohol her, Herr Hart? Seit meiner Darm-OP nicht
mehr, aber vorher habe ich auch nur bei Gelegenheit, weil Feiern getrunken. Okay, was haben Sie getrunken?
Weiß ich nicht, das, was es gab. Okay, so, treiben Sie Sportregelmäßig?
Hab ich jetzt hüttchen, wenn einer sagt, dass er nur bei Gelegenheit trinkt, ja,
dann muss man sich fragen, was er getrunken hat, das macht man nicht. Sport, habe ich früher als
junger Mann, habe ich sehr viel Sport gemacht. Ich bin immer mitgelaufen, wenn es so Marathonläufe gab,
ja so wissen Sie, und ich bin viel gejockt gelaufen, ich habe viel Fitness gemacht, aber seit jetzt
im Alter Darm-OP mache ich nicht mehr viel. Ich laufe morgens immer noch, morgens, aber das war es.
Okay, ich verstehe. Ja, so Sie sind verheiratet und haben Sie Kinder? Ja, ich habe vier Kinder.
Okay, so sind Sie gesund?
Meine Kinder sind gesund, ja.
Ja, Gott sei Dank, gut. Jetzt, Sie sind Rentner, Herr Rett. So, früher, was haben Sie gemacht,
als beruflich?
Früher, was ich beruflich gemacht habe, ich bin Architekt.
Okay, so wie ist Ihr Impfstatus? Sind Sie gegen Kinderkrankheit und auch Corona geimpft?
Ja, ganz normale Impfungen, die es in Deutschland gibt, eine Corona bin ich dreimal geimpft.
Okay, sehr gut. So, Sie haben, ja, haben Sie Stress im Alltag?
Die Kinder sind schon alle aus dem Haus. Ich lebe mit meiner Frau zusammen, wir lassen das uns gut
gehen, eigentlich habe ich keinen Stress. Okay, wissen Sie, seit der Damopäden haben wir uns auch ein
bisschen zurückgezogen vom Alltagsgeschäft. Wir machen nicht mehr viel, wir lassen es gut gehen.
Eigentlich habe ich keinen Stress. Ja, ich verstehe, so gut. Ja, gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen
in Ihrer Familie, von denen ich wissen sollte. Ich meine Ihre Eltern oder wenn es die Schwester geht.
Ich habe eine Schwester. Meine Schwester hat Bluthochdruck und Diabetes und Rheuma, aber sonst geht es ihr gut.
Okay, so, sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben oder? Nein, die sind noch am Leben. Ja, ich verstehe.
Hatten Sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen? Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, ja, so, herher, jetzt möchte ich ganz kurz zusammenfassieren, wenn ich etwas falsch verstehe oder vergesse,
bitte geben, korrigieren Sie mich. Okay, so, Sie haben seit gestern Abend sehr stark
ein Brust und strahlen auch in den Rücken aus. Richtig. Und Sie haben auch Herzstrasen und auch
Schwindelkeit. Ja, Schwindelkeit? Schwindelkeit gibt es nicht, nur Schwindel. Schwindelkeit ist ein
Punkt. Ja, ja, Schwindelkeit. Und ja, es ist Ihnen ein Beinödem vor vier Tagen aufgefallen, aber zurzeit es gibt keine Ödemer, ja.
Ja, Sie haben auch Durchfall nach dem Darmkrebsoperationen. Seit der Darmkrebsoperation ist besser, ne? Seit dem, ja, ja, richtig.
So, ist das, ja, alles, so, möchten Sie etwas noch hinzufügen oder fragen Sie?
Was Sie erzählt haben war alles richtig. Okay, okay, jetzt werde, ich möchte, was mache ich alles erklären.
Ich werde Ihnen auch Blut abnehmen und dann eine Herzutrasche durchführen. Je nach Ergebnis können wir vielleicht eine Herzkatheter durchführen.
Okay. Ja, so, jetzt Sie sind am Monitor, ich komme gleich.
Alles klar. Okay.
Danke schön. Haben Kolleginnen andere Fragen? Ja, Hüsten, Ausruf und Refle habe ich nicht gefragt.
Hüsten, habe ich nicht.
Entschuldigung, ich komme sowas. Nein, Hüsten habe ich nicht.
Ich habe keinen Hüsten.
Haben Sie Sauris aufstoßen oder Wämmungen?
Nicht, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Sort brennen auch? Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Was ist das für Sie?
Hallo, etwas fragen? Ja, natürlich.
Ist bei Ihnen am Betroffenen Beine überwarmt oder etwas bekannt?
Ob es, das ist ja wieder weg, aber Sie meinen, ob ich damals eine Überwärmung gemerkt habe.
Meinen Sie das? Ja.
Nein, es war nicht warm, es war nur dick.
Und zweite Frage, bekommt die Hochlagerung zu Ihnen etwas Linderung damals?
Bekommt die Hochlagerung Linderung ist falsches Deutsch, das geht nicht.
Bekommt die Hochlagerung zu Ihnen?
Geht nicht, das ist falsch, aber ich habe verstanden, was Sie meinen.
Ich sage das Richtige, ich überlege gerade.
Wichtige Wörter, wörtliche Wörter.
Hat die Hochlagerung eine Linderung gebracht, kann man sagen?
Oder kam es zu einer Linderung, wenn Sie Ihr Beinhof gelagert haben?
So, das geht.
Ich habe damals ehrlich gesagt, meine Beine versucht hochzulagern,
aber es ist dadurch nicht besser gegangen, es ist ganz plötzlich weggegangen.
Danke.
Okay, können wir anfangen, Herr Herr Alsars-Gechpre?
Ja, können wir anfangen?
Ja, bitte.
Guten Morgen Frau Obererstin, ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Dann möchte ich Ihnen gerne vorstellen, hätten Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, sehr gerne.
Es geht um Gustav Hart, er ist 70 Jahre alt und 1,79 m groß, 80 kg schwer.
Herr Gustav Hart hat sich heute Morgen bei uns wegen, seit gestern bestehende, plötzlich aufgetretene,
gestehende Angina Pectoris vorgestellt.
Ich würde nie sagen mit Angina Pectoris, ich würde immer sagen Brustschmerzen.
Brustschmerzen, okay.
Angina Pectoris ist immer ein bisschen typisch für Herz dann, ne?
Ich würde lieber sagen mit Brustschmerzen vorgestellt.
Okay, Brustschmerzen.
Kann man sagen, können Sie sagen, auch Angina Pectoris, aber ich würde immer allgemein alles sagen, ich würde immer sagen mit Brustschmerzen.
Der Patient hat seit dieser, sternal Schmerzen, sternal Brustschmerzen.
Sternal sagt man auch nicht, wir sagen immer retro sternale Schmerzen.
Retro sternal.
Ja, kann man auch sagen, ne?
Also Brustschmerzen oder retro sternale Schmerzen, kann man alles sagen, ne?
Retro sternales Druckgefühl, retro sternale Schmerzen.
Angina Pectoris ist immer so, mehr so, wir haben den Verdacht, dass es irgendwas in Richtung KHK gehen könnte, ne?
Dann legen Sie sich schon sehr fest.
Verstehen Sie etwas?
Ja, ja, ja, ich verstehe.
Okay.
Der Patient berichtete, dass die Schmerzen in den ganzen Brust und auch in den Rücken ausstrahlen würde.
Brust oder defus Torax, Hocam?
Bitte?
Sie haben gesagt, nicht nur Brust, nur Torax.
Brust und Torax ist ja dasselbe.
Das, was der Patient versteht, Torax ist einfach Fachbegriff.
Okay.
Ja, das kann man alles sagen.
Ja, und, ja, der Patient erwähnt, dass diese Beschwerden sind, sind erste Episode.
Und alle Beschwerden waren im Ruhe aufgetreten.
Dann so...
waren aufgetreten oder, Hocam?
Ja, Sie erzählt ja jetzt, ne?
Sie erzählt ja jetzt im Vergangenheit, jetzt kann sie das sagen.
Die Beschwerden waren in Ruhe aufgetreten.
Ist aufgetreten oder ist auch getreten?
Ist aufgetreten, ist mehr geht nicht, würde ich nicht sagen?
Seien vielleicht.
Ja, Seien kann sie sagen oder Waren kann sie auch sein, geht beides.
Sie war ja nicht dabei, sie hat es ja nur gehört.
Okay.
Ja.
Die Schmerz sind, hätten sich im Verlauf der Zeit schlimmer geworden und...
Nein, nein, stopp.
Verschlimmert.
Ja, hätte ich...
Verschlimm im Verlauf der Zeit verschlimmer.
Und die...
dann Patient mit dem Rettungswagen im Krankenhaus geliefert.
Ja, als begleitet Symptome klackte er über Tachycardi,
Vertigo und Dyspne.
Die vegetative Anamnese sei unauffällig bis auf Nükturi und Durchfall.
Also...
Wenn du eine Frage des Pürelais Symptomem,
oder auch hauptbech verdünnt, welcher,
des Pürelais Symptomem, und bursch merzen.
Bekleidung Symptomem, oder ja, vegetative Anamnese?
Ja, ja, ist ja...
Die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen,
seien sich verschlimmern, oder?
Verschlimmern, weil es ist blürer.
Nein, sich geht gar nicht.
Hätten sich...
Hätten sich verschlimmert, sie hat es schon richtig gesagt.
Ah, okay, okay.
Die Schmerzen hätten sich verschlimmern, oder verschlimmern,
weil die Schmerzen ist blürer.
Nein, die Schmerzen hätten sich verschlimmern.
Verschlimmern.
Okay, danke.
Ja, ich weiß, was Sie meinen.
Nein, nicht plummern, man muss sagen,
hätten sich verschlimmert, verschlimmert, bleibt verschlimmert.
Ja.
Wenn man so sagt, die Schmerzen hätten sich verschlimmert,
ja, so, so ist richtig.
Hier ist ja keine Kistik.
Okay.
Die Frage nach...
Ich weiß, dass Brühe
bei Nausea und Emesis
wurde verneint, wussten auch.
So in der vegetative Anamnese,
an vegetative, an...
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich Sie sagen kann.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Alles ist gut, das Deutsche ist gut.
Alles ist gut.
Klar, es ist gut.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich Sie sagen kann.
Das ist gut.
war sehr gut, das Deutsch ist gut, also alles gut. Aber man sagt nicht, er hätte an einem
Damkarzinom gelitten. Das ist so wie, er hätte, das sagt man nicht. Wie soll ich das sagen?
Leider an Kolonkarzinom kann man das. Was? Ja, genau. Und man leide an Kolonkarzinom sagt man jetzt
auch nicht, weil es ist vorbei. Er habe gelitten, sagt man dann auch nicht.
Sagen Sie einfach, wenn er zum Beispiel jetzt folgen hätte vom Damkarzinom,
wenn das noch weitergeht, dann leidet er darunter. Ja, es ist ja vorbei. An Vorerkrankungen hatte er
ein Damkarzinom. Es ist vorbei. Er leide heißt, er ist immer noch, hat er ja nicht mehr.
Genial. Ja, die erste Diagnose war in 2001 für Kolonkarzinom und das wurde mit Chemo-Terepo und
Operationen behandelt. Er regelmäßig nach Sorgeuntersuchung. Und nach Sorgeuntersuchung.
Es wurde beim Patienten eine Tonselektomie als Kind durchgeführt worden. Es wurde durchgesucht worden, geht nicht.
Ja, sehr gut. Er hatte auch einen Sportunfall. Damals er sein linker Arm ist verletzt.
Damals ist verletzt geht nicht. Damals ist verletzt. Damals, entweder so wie Sie das immer sagen,
damals sei sein linker Arm verletzt gewesen oder damals war sein linker Arm verletzt gewesen.
Ich sag das immer anders im FSB. Damals sei sein Arm verletzt gewesen.
Er ist allergisch auf Penicillin. Sind Sie etwas, die noch sagen können? Ich will nur etwas sagen.
Wenn er nicht operiert wurde, dann können Sie auch sagen, dass es auch gut war.
Er hatte eine Penicillin-Allergie und laut Patient mit schwerer Kreislaufreaktion. Wenn einer bewusstlos wird,
wenn er auf Allergie reagiert, dann hat er schon eine Kreislaufreaktion. Dann ist das schon ein anaphylaktischer Schock.
Dann kann man sagen mit schwerer Kreislaufreaktion. Er hatte eine richtige Penicillin-Allergie.
Er hat ein bisschen hier und ein bisschen jucken. Nein, er hat richtig Kreislaufreaktion.
Er hat Medikamente gebraucht. Der Patient beschreibt, er hat eine Penicillin-Allergie
und mit schwerer Kreislaufreaktion. Der Patient wollte damit einen schweren anaphylaktischen Schock berückschreiben.
Kreislaufreaktion reicht. Es sind keine Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er habe seit vor zwei Jahren mit dem Racken aufgehört, aber davor gibt er 30 Päckensign.
Davor gibt er 30 Päckensign.
Er hat 30 Päckensign.
Er ist verheiratet und habe vier Kinder, die gesund sind.
Er ist seit Rentner früher als Architekt gearbeitet. Sein Impfstatus sei vollständig.
Sein Reise an einem Nese sei unauffällig.
Er ist nicht prüfungsrelevant.
An der Familienanamnese ergab sich seine Schwester.
An der Familienanamnese ergab sich eine arterielle Hypertonie diabetes mellitus und rheumatische Arthritis.
An der Familienanamnese ergab sich 5,5 Punkte.
Was muss man in der Prüfung sagen?
Aus der Familienanamnese ergab sich eine Diabetesmellitus.
Alle Anamnestationen an den Eltern auf eine Myocardinfarkt hin.
Die Typische sind nicht so typisch, aber die Brust ist schmerzlos.
Ich würde sagen, die Pulmenarembolie.
Sie können nicht sagen, dass die Anamnese für die Pulmenarembolie spricht.
Sie müssen sich vorher entscheiden.
Ich habe gesagt, wenn man zur Diagnose kommt,
kann man festlegen und sagen, das ist ein Herzinfarkt.
Man kann sagen, es könnte sich hierbei, weil der Patient retroschnelle Schmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in den Rücken angibt und Luftnot hat.
Sie können sagen, wegen der Rauchanamnese, die Kotin als Risikofaktor,
es ist nicht viel.
Es könnte sich hierbei um eine KKK handeln.
Es könnte sich hierbei aber auch um eine Lungenembolie handeln.
Es könnte ein akut Coronasyndrom sein.
Es könnte sich hierbei um eine Rettostarnale Schmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in den Rücken angibt und Luftnot hat.
Und die Nikotin Abusus.
Über längere Jahre.
Sie haben jetzt ein Jahr geraucht, aber 30 Jahre ist schon ein Wort.
Als differential Diagnose.
Das hört sich doch schon viel besser an.
Genau so macht man das als differential Diagnose.
Es gibt eine Lungenembolie.
Eine Lungenembolie?
Kommt auch gut.
Jetzt müssen Sie erst mal begründen, warum eine Lungenembolie in Frage kommt.
Der Patient hat vor vier Tagen eine Lungenembolie.
Für eine Lungenembolie spricht ein Bein ödem.
Wenn man eine Lungenembolie ist, ist es erst mal eine Lungenemolie.
Dafür spricht die Beinschwellung erst mal.
Dafür spricht die Beinschwellung vor vier Tagen.
Warum?
Es könnte auch ein ödem sein.
Aber zurzeit gibt es keine ödem.
Eine Schmerz hat er vor vier Tagen.
Es ist plötzlich weggegangen.
Es war einseitig.
Es ist ein sehr guter Bein.
Die Lungenembolie spricht die Luftnot und die Schmerzen.
Es ist plötzlich weggegangen.
Die Luftnot spricht die schmerzhafte Beinschwellung vor vier Tagen.
Es ist eine sehr gute Beinschwellung.
Die Leuchttrache wird für Sie darauf gekommen.
Der Prüfer möchte hören,
dass es eine Leuchttrache ist.
Der Trombus hat sich gelöst.
Der Prüfer ist glücklich.
Was könnte noch für eine Lungenembolie sprechen?
Der Prüfer hat einen Rechtschenkelblock im EKG.
Der Prüfer ist glücklich.
Was machen Sie im Labor?
Sie müssen noch ein Verb für die Lungenembolie machen.
Pro BNP ist erhöht.
Das Recht der Herze ist dekompensiert.
Was haben Sie gemacht?
Pro BNP?
Pro BNP ist erhöht.
Was machen Sie noch?
Was sehen Sie?
Pro BNP ist erhöht.